what's going on guys it's May which
means it's just about bikini season and
summer box office movie season and we're
going to make our top 10 summer movie
box office predictions qualify for this
list must fall between the first weekend
in May and the last weekend in August I
know some of you are like hey it's not
summer it's spring I don't make the
rules I just abide by them you'd be
smart to do the same and to make the
predictions we have an awesome crew of
box office savvy individuals first off I
can't believe it's your very first time
with us she is the senior editor at
Rotten Tomatoes grade ring he is the
director of development at Collider
video you know I'm from Fandango one
half of the schmoes Kristian harloff and
uh he's our old pal but he's got a new
show coming up check out summer movie
report Oh somewhat apropos starting May
9th I'm screwed John useless Dan Merle
good to see you buddy and before we get
started let's take a quick peek at
everybody's list
first up Kristian harloff like everyone
else he's got Captain America Civil War
and finding dory at 1 & 2 he's the only
one with Warcraft on his list and he's
the highest on Alice Through the Looking
Glass next up gray Drake she's the only
one with sausage party on her list and
one of two with ghostbusters making her
top 10 next up our own Dan Merle he's
the highest on Jason Bourne he's the
only one with neighbors - and secret
life of pets on his list with secret
life of pets coming in number 3 and my
list the correct list on the highest on
ghostbusters with it at number 3 and I'm
the only one with the rocks Central
Intelligence on their list so guys um
let's talk about your list
great let's start with you what's one
movie on your list where you think might
sneak up and surprise us god I hope it's
ghostbusters I put it at number 10 yeah
only because the jury's still out that
trailer was terrible
uh-huh and it didn't get me excited but
I have so much faith in Paul Feig and
Melissa McCarthy together and Kristen
Wiig - I have ghosts
Buster's the highest of anyone I have it
number three Wow yeah that's high
you just took yourself way out of this
competition well there aren't a ton of
female centric comedies this summer
and if Ghostbusters is good I think it
could catch fire sure but look we're
looking at the most disliked trailer in
YouTube's history now I'm not saying
this movie cannot wind up being a hit it
can but I think it has too much working
against it right now to put itself in
the top 10 I hope that they turn it
around I love the creative team behind
this movie and I hope it does well I
just couldn't put it on my list I
couldn't ignore it's got a lot going
against it right now Christian what's a
movie that um you were like huh you know
what maybe I'll put it in there you know
at my number 9 spot
I have Warcraft now in bold from what
Duncan Jones being a hardcore fan his
last two movies you know with moon and
source code which I really enjoyed yeah
I think this movie's gonna shock a weird
choice it is well he's a fan it's a big
fan of them of the game if it's a good
film that's why I put it into my time
because I think that people will go out
talk about it word of mouth and get it
in there
but if it doesn't deliver then it's not
gonna make it yeah I mean here's the
thing video game movies no way no
they're actually the worst yeah it's not
going to attract people like me that
don't play the game I just think
Warcraft was big five years ago I don't
hear people talking about Warcraft I'm
talking about minecraft because I'm
talking about a lot of other games I'm
not a gamer myself so I'm kind of in
grazed camp where it's just not really
something that interests me as far as
online gaming movies I'm waiting for
FanDuel the movie okay the movie that I
actually have way way high up on my list
is Secret Life of pets I have that oh I
have that at number three on my list
yeah I don't think anybody else has it
on theirs and the trailers have been
entertaining they've been fun trailers
it's from the same people that did
minions I think with Zootopia we've seen
like how a strong trailer that gets out
ahead of the pack can really lift a
movie and so I'm betting big on it yeah
furries will go to the movies pets is
not gonna be finding dory there's no way
there's no way because it's Ellen and
Dory is a trusted brand yes and it's
also coming off a Pixar but I think that
I don't think the pets is a bad bad I
think three is a bit high but I think
that it it could certainly do what
pickable media kind of came in or made
that kind of money so gray brought up
that it probably won't be dory and to
that end we all have the same one and to
one Civil War to finding dory yeah what
why do you think we all went Civil War
number one what's behind that Ultron was
number two but guardians topped the
summer Iron Man 3 top the summer Marvel
has a track record of topping the summer
and this is this isn't really spread out
summer there's not a lot of slam dunks
and I feel like Civil War is one of the
very few movies that you know is going
to break at least 300 well yeah because
that's the brand that is consistent with
the quality of the product please be
good I want to put Christian on the spot
right now if okay so you have Civil War
number one right if you had to pick one
movie that could possibly be thrown it
nothing nothing no no way no because Dan
said it's going to possibly make 300
million its kind of making about almost
close to 200 million on its opening
weekend it's just it will be the biggest
movie I definitely the summer gotcha
I'd give Dory a puncher's chance mm-hmm
I would and you know if Suicide Squad is
amazing if you guardians of the galaxy
this one come out in August and just
shoot up and and beat Civil War you
never know because the thing about
Suicide Squad is that it has real
guardians of the galaxy vibe nobody
really knows what it's gonna do and this
is like margot robbie and her underpants
man yeah get on Google which x-men
apocalypse versus Suicide Squad kind of
a superhero smackdown there and we all
have them kind of close on our list dan
you're the only person with Suicide
Squad higher what are our thoughts on
these two movies even the teaser at the
end of Days of Future past was so cool
that I was like I'm already buying a
ticket Days of Future past did well but
I don't feel like apocalypse is critic
proof at this point I feel bad for
Suicide Squad a little bit because it's
not gonna be allowed to stand on its own
it's an unfortunate shadow of the
reaction to Batman V Superman and if
there are problems with the movie I'm
worried that people are gonna be too
Batman is in it and he was one of the
most positive elements of nd Superman
and and people love the Joker maybe when
they love Batman they want the job so
see that's a great point if he really
does come out swinging that could get a
lot more butts in the theaters Dan and
Christian you are the only two here who
have
through the looking-glass the next
installment of the Alice in Wonderland
saga yes every year there's a movie I
put on my list and I just go oh yeah and
this was that movie but I looked at how
much money the first movie made yeah I
said even if this takes a 50% drop it's
still in that range Wow I put it hard to
anything number I didn't wanna put it on
I saw it
mm-hmm I can't say anything about it
except that I liked it better okay so
you might be right
who else is pretty excited that Jason
Bourne is back on Matt Damon yes oh
great
looks amazing yes it looks so good
because I love watching cities get
destroyed mm-hmm the last one with Matt
Damon was like over 200 million really
Yahoo and this looks great yeah yes
score I put it hot people love spy
movies the spy flash summer did really
well Spectre which was a mediocre at
best James Bond movie still made a lot
of money
Kingsman was amazing and a lot of money
rogue nation made a lot of money people
love the spy movies and the trailer for
this looks great
yeah it's you're got the whole team back
together I think it'll do really well
you're the only one that sausage party
on your list the yes seth rogen comedy
my favorite kind of party this one this
is a little bit of an optimistic picture
right because it has a couple of weird
things going on well more than a couple
yeah but it's our rated and it's
animated and so it's gonna be tough for
this one to really get into that top ten
I just want it to the trailers great I
am so with you
it's not on my list but I want it to be
number one I want it to crush I just
think it has too much working against it
right now
in order to make that top 10 for me it
was the Battle of the Rogen's my number
10 spot was between sausage party and
neighbors too and I went back and forth
probably three or four times yeah I
ended up going with the kind of proven
established hit it comes out in a little
bit more of a complementary slot in the
summer so that's where I put that one it
was back and forth for me on neighbors
too because I need it I need a comedy on
my list but I gambled on Central
Intelligence Wow with Kevin Hart and the
rock the rock brings people in the rock
surprised us all with San Andreas last
summer
you know nobody put San Andreas on our
list last summer and it wasn't the top
and they're promoting the hell out of
this I think this could get big general
audiences into multiplexes Star Trek
beyond Justin Lin is moving from fast
and furious to the Fast and Furious in
space you know we love watching Chris
Pine and this time he's just gonna like
we pine for pie truly do he's just going
to be punching more stuff it looks like
yes
this goes back though to what we're
talking about with ghostbusters for me
is that I think that also the trailer is
going to hurt this movie little it
didn't feel like a Star Trek movie Star
Trek giris were like what am I watching
here Star Trek has always been a tough
sell
JJ's reboot did great trick in the
darkness did less yeah and so that does
that says to me that the franchise isn't
on the on the incline it's going down
I'm the only person to have Spielberg's
The BFG on their list that movie could
be lightning in a bottle I felt no buzz
on this movie yeah people don't know
what the movie is The BFG you don't even
know what it's about
and this is a very family saturated
summer the Sony animated movies and
cartoons Pixar and Angry Birds I
remember a Roald Dahl book I remember
that book from when I'm a kid right that
was pretty much it
yeah that's pretty although The BFG I
can't stop help thinking does that stand
for big job you know it's a video I
think yeah everything I don't know the
dangerous initials I'm the only one that
didn't put the second installment of the
Ninja Turtles on his list
god bless you sir yeah no slept on the
first one didn't put it on my top ten
made the top ten
this one looks better that's not saying
much it's not say much but it looks
better and it was proven that people
liked already the younger generation
they obviously somebody want to see the
last one and this one is giving people
like me even excited about it I echo
those sentiments as well dan you're the
only one that didn't put the
Independence Day revisiting on your list
Independence Day resurgence yeah we had
Jurassic world blast you'd be like Oh
drastic world did great so Independence
Day he's gonna do great
Jurassic world was its own separate
whole thing I'm selling Chris Pratt
you're selling the new dinosaurs it was
its own separate thing I hate to say
this and I hope I'm wrong I feel like
this is going to be more terminator
genisys as far as reaction no not the
quality of the movie I feel like the
response is going to be more Genesis of
people going like huh I think it's going
to be a terrible movie but I can't wait
to just jam popcorn in my face and watch
this movie on the screen and I really
think that's going to be
a lot of people's thoughts yeah see the
lesser hemsworth kill some aliens why
not
okay here's some movies that none of us
had on our list that are fairly big
openings the conjuring - gray puts on
the spot - spooky oh god no I can't wait
I hope that it gets in the top ten it
just won't
no one has ice age collision course Dan
you said it's a stopped summer as far as
family moving box office it's not
climbing on this movies it's declining
it's been I think four years since the
last one just didn't find her important
Angry Birds oh no chance I talked about
a movie that's a few years too late as
anyone playing Angry Birds anymore no
they needed a candy crush movie is what
they needed no one had Pete's dragon on
their way that was close I was close I'm
Pete's dragons it was another one that I
just don't think there's enough buzz
around it again to put it into the top
ten but I wouldn't be shocked if I made
it we all had dory
you guys picked Alice those are the ones
that are gonna bump movies like Peter
just out ten pole moves used to be like
four and it seems like every weekend
there's a tentpole movie yeah this is
going to be the summer where I think we
don't see one we don't see like a lone
ranger or one of them fail I think we're
gonna see three four five of these big
budget moves fail well there's only one
way to find out
wait until the fall look at the numbers
what did you think of our predictions
what was too high what was too low do
you think ghostbusters will do as well
as I did also we want you to compete
against us go to screen junkies calm
slash box-office game and make your top
10 predictions Dan you have a little
something associated with that huh
that's right we will be tracking
everyone's results all summer long on my
new show it's Ramirez midnight every
week myself
Sasha pearl raver some awesome guests
will be breaking down the box office and
we'll be keeping track week by week of
the top ten results what movies got
bumped in what movies got bumped out
who's leading in the contest how badly
am i doing I think it's gonna be pretty
bad but it's gonna be really hold on
we're gonna be tracking this is the
biggest summer movie season and the most
unpredictable one I think we've had in a
very long time so every Monday morning
on screen junkies plus summer movie
report with Dan Mars oh man that is so
awesome and that's so cool that you're
making it interactive like that let's
like the future it's fun yeah that's why
we wanted to everyone to go screw
Jackie's comm and sign up so that we can
track everyone's was
volts and you know we we will know
before the end of the summer how
everyone's doing that's really cool um
and you know what else is really cool
these people that came and talked to us
today what a super cool panel grade rake
thank you for making your screen junkies
debut Christian always a pleasure my
friend and Dan Merle uh yeah I'll see
you across the hall absolutely I want to
thank you for watching I'm how run dick
hit me up on Twitter bye bye we often
refer to that device that he used in
when the car slipped over the winter
soldiers coming after him and he cuts a
hole in the concrete to escape as his
lightsaber yep we're going to do for the
the bloopers real we were actually just
gonna turn it into a lightsaber when you
hit the button on it yeah that's kind of
laying on the ground and he goes